study from the time before it'd be easy
some of you have seen this before by
promises poetry to the end so think
about trying to do EBE for you let's
this magnet Ori are mentioning I need to
save big data so we're doing this at
workshop maybe for solving some some
kind of dating miss big data so you have
a user who wants to you know date on the
internet and you want to publish user
want to publish some solve a dating
profile
so the dating profile contains all kinds
of our personal information pictures
email addresses age hobbies blah blah
blah and you really want to leave me
access to this profile to people who fit
your dating criterion for instance so
what you want to do is you essentially
want to what a B allows you to do is
unclip the profile and does in addition
specify SS policy think of this as
specifying like a bathing preference
something very mundane like tall dark
and handsome but of course we are monk
friends here and you know people who
know better really in the Bay Area where
you wanna see the cost of a PhD income
design so say so a B allows you to
specify policy like this think of this
as the attribute earlier we talked about
attribute being a string X but when we
have a B for circuits you can also
encrypt or circular so so so users come
along they register for the website you
know you have different users when they
register they may be present a diploma
to the dating website and then they get
keys they're customized to the kind of
you know the kind of characteristics
that they have right so in this
particular case I'll be able to decrypt
the profile and I thought you look on
the internet but then you know for the
people who do not satisfy the who do not
satisfy this this policy over here they
should not be able decrypt the profile
right this is what ABC says moreover a
be a guarantee security against
collusion so even if all these people
come together you have a collusion this
you cannot learn anything over the
profile so this way set of the store of
a B and the trouble with using a B II is
that if it doesn't protect the written
preference it doesn't protect the
attributes and what can you imagine many
scenarios where you know not only is
your pro power sensitive you can think
of many scenarios where your dating
preferences are sensitive that you do
not want to review the people except
maybe for those four
dimension rating preferences so you want
these people to not still not be able to
learn anything about your dating
preferences you want to protect the
privacy of attribute all right so this
is now what what we'll be talking about
so earlier we have already seen a queue
based encryption so the committee has
proposed stronger notions of attribute
of encryption that namely predictor and
function encryption the other ABI but
that in addition provides some privacy
guarantee for the attributes all right
let me try to tell you what these
objects are so for simple let me start
the syntax of these attributes so of
attribute based encryption predict
encryption function question they have
the same syntax and the same correctness
guarantees so that's encryption
algorithm that basically input the
public key and attribute X and a message
and produces a ciphertext addition you
can create keys for predicates and the
basic syntax and correctness requirement
is that if you have a key for which the
predicate reversals draw an X you can
decrypt and recover the message m and
you have a key for for which the
predicate is false when you try to equip
you get put alright so in some sense the
keys to tell you why the P of X is true
or false
listen sometimes inevitable alright then
the next question what are the security
guarantees in a b e this is sort of the
weakest followed by stronger and
stronger there's no security guarantee
regarding accidentally to add in all of
them they are going to have to guarantee
that if you have a key for sure
practical is false
you should not learn anything about
message m so in the case of a becs we
never have any security guarantee put in
X we can essentially in a be essentially
always published academically and that's
really what other schemes are doing
predictor encryption our professor
slightly stronger guarantee it hides X
so if you have a key for which the
particle is for T hash X so think of it
in the context of dating as you know
everyone who do not satisfy your dating
profile do not see the rainbow flag and
that's what makes sense you know if they
can decrypt your profile in some sense
there's probably other clues for which
that might review review information
about X already so this is sort of the
intermediate security requirements
function encryption provides a stronger
security
security guarantee namely that in the
case where the protocol is false it has
both the X attribute and the message m
in a case that the predicate is true
here you cannot hope to hide em anymore
but you still hire X and let me say that
by hiding X you cannot hope to high exit
completely you will reveal P of X what I
mean was your high X everything about X
beyond the fact that P of X the evil to
true of boss all right so some of you
may be more familiar with the definition
of function encryption it doesn't talk
about message this is essentially
equivalent right from the given someone
who holds the secret key and the
ciphertext used to hide X this
particular sceptic think of this as a
guarantee for one key and once every
thanks for now in fact this is for the
simplified setting where there's only
one key but security guarantee or so
hostmask illusion string so in
particular if you're in this column over
here and you collect many keys for which
the particular is false you still should
not learn X so right so the formal
security
definition can be essentially the same
as the one for a ve the s10 naturally to
the setting for hiding X all right so
I'm not going to say precisely what the
I'm not going to present the attack
security game so this is the roughly the
differences that and the main open
problem in the study of function
encryption is whether we can construct
partial encryption schemes for all
circuits so what we seen from Vino's
talk is that we do know how to construct
actually based encryption or all
circuits and the out of Yui and really
we want to get to function encryption
which is the hardest but even before we
get to partial encryption the natural
question is can we even get to practical
encryption for circuits so that made
quickly and the answers that all this
sort of yes and I'm going to give you a
quick summary of prior works so this is
sort of a summary of prior works so that
the white regions and the gray regions
at high level the white regions
corresponds to the the classes for which
wave constructions
understand that well understood
assumptions and the great region
corresponds to for function for
constructions and the less one these two
assumptions let me say this a little bit
more so let me now say earlier we do
have attribute based encryption for
circuits and we can get them this is the
region over here so a B is a subclass of
function encryption so a B for all
circuits and we know how to do this
understand out of your assumption moving
up a little bit more we know how to get
practical and functional encryption but
only for very simple functions functions
that are contained within NC 1 even much
simpler than that so functions that
essentially computer inner products plus
a variant of inner product like trash
show of you know product or something
like that
think of it as you can essentially only
do it for simple for inner product so
this is a very small cutter functions
and in this case we actually have
constructions both from the sender out
every assumption and we have
construction based on pairings so by
linear maps standard some sort of value
image right so that's what region 1 & 2
that's all that we know essentially from
send assumptions and finally we do know
function encryption we do have cut the
construction for partial encryption for
all circuits however are they rely on
fairly strong and not so long as the
assumptions of vestigation and multi
linear maps and if you were here at the
previous workshop if you really look at
the status of these assumptions you
realize that the setters are not
complicated so we really want to avoid
complicated situations and as long it's
a real cryptography stone use
obfuscation
we're going to try to avoid what we
really try to focus on how far we can go
will rely only on standard assumptions
how weo
rows n 14 there's a link on Facebook to
do a PowerPoint slide to go into
yeah yeah yeah it's all about Facebook
it's about social media and yeah right
so yeah we built with you more right so
well we're cryptographers so the menu is
that for this talk is we solve the the
next open problem we make serious
progress towards trying to get function
encryption for all circuits we get
practical encryption for all circuits
and standard sub-exponential or W
assumption so the Assumption here is
basically the same one that we know
presenter for a B for circuits all right
I'm going back to the picture basically
we unlatch this white region over here
to this much bigger white region over
here this is sort of what practical
encryption is so there's still a little
bit that we didn't quite catch but this
is the best we can do in some sense for
this is the best we know how to do from
our w/e at this moment right let me say
a bit about the parameter thought skims
so that we got shot ciphertext and shot
keys the parameter essentially inherited
from the ABA scheme string so we have
short ciphertext whose whose size
depends polynomially in the length of
the attribute x on the death of the
circuit and on the security parameter
all right the keys also have this very
nice property and in fact not only do
the other protect shots the encryption
algorithm also runs in time polynomial
in in this parameters so this is a
notion of compactness which something
that are people using lately to butor
more complex primitives we shall talk
about later in the talk
sorry yeah yeah yeah the same perimeter
the same qualitative and quantitative
dependencies in business talk so the
same this is a lever construction all
right so I want to tell you what our
construction looks like yeah we got
ready encryption which is the set of the
slightly weaker one-sided notion when
you put the X if you get keys that
cannot decrypt the cipher that you only
get keys for which P of X is false but
this is already a big progress you know
almost there we went from here but here
you know so we'll get there yeah I know
I'll go back to function encryption
later oh sure
so here's a quick recap so the starting
point of our construction is that if the
scheme that we know talked about so we
think of a be e encryption algorithm
that takes a public index excellent
message and the opposite ciphertext with
respect to some our public as we not
explain the the bgg plus a be e have the
property that has some sort of recording
property namely that given an encryption
for the attribute X together with X in
the clear and some predicate in the
clear you can turn it into an encryption
of the attribute P of X so you start out
with an encryption just focus on
attribute part you start out with
attribute being X you can turn it the
attribute into P of X by sort of
performing public operations on this a
protection but that's a switch here this
encryption is no longer respect to the
same public key from before it's going
to be a public key that depends on P
then once you get here the the secret
key is essentially is if you want to the
equipment P of X is 0
that's how notion was true you basically
sort of create a key corresponding to
this particular public key and and the
evolution of in 0 that's basically what
Ben was saying so this is our starting
point this is our ABS scheme that we
will be using and this is sort of the
roughly speaking essentially the only
property that we need from the EBC
so the stacking former construction
starts off with this idea of a gopis a
of namely oh sorry yes of course you're
computing already the policy and X if
during the equip ssin during the equip
ssin so the encryption this is the
actual cipher text the decryption works
in this are three steps so given the
policy and the X you compute encryption
P of X then you decrypt this value so
there's some sort of a whole room of the
evaluation going on during the Egyptian
this is basically the same operation of
in osaka'
I'm sorry no I'm sorry this is just a
recap of what we know talked about for I
haven't said what our construction is
just to make sure that we have the same
interface any questions
alright now I can tell you what our
construction is the starting point of
our construction is the construction
goals I say oh what are we trying to do
right we want to protects so the natural
thing to do is to put and cryptex using
a offici scheme and so we want to stop
put the X or and bring some sort of
computational X so the natural thing to
do in some sense is to first encrypt X
using a fully homomorphic encryption
scheme for the construction suffice us
to use a symmetric key fully homomorphic
encryption scheme so I'm going to denote
this as this is a fully homomorphic
encryption X under the key K so so the
think about the encryption algorithm as
follows
the first thing you do is on input X
pick a random key K encrypt X under K
and treat this as the new attribute and
then run your original bg+ a be e and
with this as your new attribute now if
you look at this at some sense which
axis already hidden because s is
protected by the officially so for the
next couple of slides let's ignore the
issue of security for now and think
about correctness how do we decrypt how
can we decrypt without knowing X no this
is just a text yeah I've got to tell you
all right this is just a separate X so
how do you decrypt you get a key for you
get the P and the secret key for P then
you try to do something it is just a
ciphertext
so not only cliff there no scale it only
Cooper no skill and cooped up because
random kfh see secret key encryption
encrypt X and decay this has the
attribute and then run the ad e any
questions for the construction is
whereas think about what decryption
might look like so I'm also going to as
part of the ciphertext this is hypertext
for our new encryption scheme as part of
the ciphertext
I will also publish the MFE encryption
of X that's okay because I see shortly
protector under the FHA this is not
going to affect intuitively it would
affect our security of X so now what do
we know now the the Decrypter is going
to see this together with this it's
going to get a P and potentially some
secret key for P but it's going to get P
for now right now what we know is that
since this is a fully homomorphic
encryption scheme if I have this
ciphertext I can compute an encryption
of P of X so this operation of computing
an encryption of P of X from the
encryption of X is some public operation
on the attribute so so we can apply this
public operation on this attribute
render a be e operations and turn this
into an encryption under the attribute
which corresponds the encryption of P of
X well you didn't affect that from an
encryption actually can go to anchors
from P of X and this is a publication so
this is a public operation that's a
puppy operation that goes from this to
this
in the ciphertext why do you then need
to add it in research this is the
attribute right I'm going to I'm going
to assume that you're a B ciphertext
doesn't contain the attribute it's
important here I'm going to separately
give you the FEC SEPA will provide that
as far as so the output here think of SS
times time into accepting this only the
only part so we separately also give you
the official encryption okay this is
sort of the cipher text with what we're
so far now there's some operation that
goes from here to here and our when
there's some public operation going from
here to here our bg+ a B scheme then
guarantees that you can turn this
attribute over here to this attribute
over here exactly yeah the operation we
compute as you officially vow of P on
the encryption of X this is the
operation on the attributes then your
your a B algorithm tells you a different
algorithm to evaluate this particle over
the one receptor so you get to do so
here I haven't talked about how the
generate the secret key yeah but really
now we want to talk about generating
secret key in some sense you know at
this point in time so that we do not
know X we don't know K so in some sense
from the decrypt this point of view
seems very hard to decrypt this thing
because you really since you don't know
anything about K you essentially don't
know anything about X right so in some
sense we won so now we're faced with a
conundrum over here we want to somehow
release a little bit of information
about K in our new cipher text right so
that you can you know check whether P of
X is 0 and yet at the same time I want
to protect Kate because if we completely
give up K you will violate security you
no longer have security from the you can
no longer can you semantic security of
the efficient scheme at the same time we
need to give a little bit of information
of ok so that you can check whether P of
X is 0
and this is actually a very hard problem
because what do we need to do is
essentially we need to give up a way for
you to test whether P of X is 0 we don't
decrypting SSL and for those of you who
know the assisting candidates our
approaches to building multi linear Maps
this is a stall I want to give you a
zero testing parameter for the predicate
P that does then somehow completely
violate security allows you to stop the
screen off these are the kind of things
that exactly what makes zero testing
hard and yet we're going to show how to
solve this problem we are well relying
only on the out of view assumption the
second difficulty if you think about it
is that it looks as if you know there's
a we haven't accomplished anything why
there's something circular about the
whole reasoning going so our goal is to
protects while being able to end able
sums of computation that you do X now
I'm trying to say I want to protect K or
only bring some so computation on K so
how is this different from trying to put
and compute extra scratch that's one
part of it so you know that this U of K
more importantly you know the
computation on K now the computation K
is a fishy decryption right on some so
what we want to do is sort of a use K to
decrypt this emphasis that attacks right
so this is a and the ciphertext is
something that you can also compute
yourself given the the the encryption
actually something you can compute
ourselves so so really the whole key
you can compute the officia encryption P
of X given our three encryption backs
so really the the the only the only
magic the really the thing that you're
trying to compute on and keep private is
the FF a secret key an FF II decryption
the key observation here is the official
decryption is a very simple function
with respect to the official secret key
so yeah it's trying to put a very simple
computation on the key K and in fact a
fishy decryption corresponds to
essentially just computing an inner
product and we know predict encryption
and function encryption schemes for
computing inner products so really what
push le using the fact that this is a
very simple computation so really we
could use a patent is very simple
function special key alright so since we
have a practical encryption of function
encryption for simple functions now we
can say let's embed this K as an
attribute and these are only doing
simple computations we can hope to
protect this attribute so here's our new
so here's our final salve attacks here's
our encryption algorithm you can input X
you pick a random key K then you compute
efficient caption of K and you treat the
concatenation of K and efficient
encryption is a new attribute so now
your new attribute has to pass an F H es
secret key and officially ciphertext and
then you'll output whatever the ABA
encryption outputs but you and then you
output the official ciphertext and you
don't output the key so that's the
entire set vertex so there's a a b e
encryption with respect to some
attribute that contains the efficient
secret key ref is that protection and
you publish the refugees have attack but
you don't publish the cake
EBE it was without position here at the
site but it's contagious thinking you
assume is that exist ID but it's not the
case we're usually in a be skin when you
give us something you can s transpose a
1 + X 1 you can just usually you
separately on the X so it nor whatever
part attacks on don't have on the X so
the AP construction up with some out of
your example just keep those out of
reason yes we'll be using the BG + you
you know X to decrypt you need to know
actually so in the previous case you
need to know X yeah so I haven't taught
you how to do could yet so you don't
know K here that's a great question yeah
so this is the ciphertext I haven't
taught you how to decrypt yet okay and
in fact with this after that you cannot
even run the previous API decryption
algorithm because the previous ABI
decryption algorithm needs to know the
anti I drew in the clear so like I said
let's focus on trying to do a decryption
so let's see how the decrypt so first of
all we can still compute on this part
because we know the sha encryption the
cipher texts contain the official
encryption of X so we can still as
before compute on this part
yeah exactly yes so you can compete on
this part and we get this thing over
here right now that's the hot part now
right
so what we really want to know now to be
able to do is to use this K to decrypt
the ciphertext which essentially
corresponds to just computing an inner
product let's pretend for now the F is a
description just confident in a
production so we want to do is to
somehow pick this and this over here and
compute the inner product we don't know
what K is
now we could now we're going to
crucially use the fact that this inner
product is a very simple function let me
say that if you can compute the inner
product this is basically the SEC
decryption of the ciphertext then you
get P of X over here then you can
process before another question the
magic is for the same reason I can stop
it so that's just a stream refuge yeah
yeah like this yes but let's assume for
now that ethnicity which is exactly
innovative okay that will come up when
talking about decryption all right so
let me tell you how to go from here to
here it's the it's the inner product of
K together with this and this is
basically a decryption of this efficient
staff attacks over here so the
decryption of this F is happening
essentially of action
you can the pH is actually number and of
the same construction you don't have to
work s one being this XYZ number if you
supply maybe you can go to predicate
encryption and just like designing a
pelican encryption for the decryption
circuit over Fiji yeah yeah you're way
ahead so you are this is slightly
orthogonal issue for now this is the
question of relation to prior work right
you know so maybe I think the offline
question also but let me finish
correctness of the algorithm any
questions for now I just let me ask
incorrectness roughly speaking we're
going to look at how the previous
hormone-free algorithm works since we we
need to do inner product which is the
sum of products so we just need to poker
so not the additions that easy part the
hard part is doing a single
multiplication so let's think of this
you are doing inner product two vectors
that's just thing are multiplying two
values for now so you essentially have
an encoding of K so you have a 1 plus K
times G and a dope acid sequence G is
actually while trying to get to
something plus K times C I'm sorry
and these are the way you hang their
multiplication gates in the BG plus AV
schemes has a very nice property that
when you combine these values you only
need to know when whenever you have
about location gate you only need to
know one of the two wires coming into
the multiplication game so this is out
so instead so you only know either C ok
and you can arrange it so that you only
know C and Ali's know K and here this is
a vector addition area that we have
while doing a multiplication on the left
wire is a secret key on the right wires
advertise disciple that you know so you
can arrange it so that you do a
multiplication get only knowing one of
the twice so then that gives you credit
addition of the matter you don't need to
know either any questions
also we're really exploiting properties
of the ABC sorry so you do each of the
multiplications bitwise addition is
completely oblivious to the wider values
computing inner product right yeah yeah
so you do
great so uh so just to summarize the
scheme just what does happen text looks
like your secret key is going to be
basically creating some sort of a be
secret key that sort of checks you want
to be able to decrypt if the decryption
of of the inner product is close to zero
basically that correspond to a
officially encryption zero so one thing
I didn't say is that in official
decryption is not only computing inner
products you have to do interpret that
we're rounding so you're not checking
whether you don't decrypt when the inner
products exactly zero but in your build
equipment the inner put that last
enzymes pointable
so for our purpose it's extremely
important that this interval has size
polynomial security parameter and this
is something that's achieved in the in
the brickowski by Quentin as an effigy
and then once you know that the inner
product lies within a certain interval
you basically give up many a de secret
keys correspond to each of these values
in the
okay
the judges
okay so anyway you've just appointed
windows for show me the the free prayers
came to achieve it you need the noise of
the evaluator cybertek to be the fall
within a polynomial size interval
because you're going to give up one
secret key for each of the points in
this interval so the the final secret
keys are many
right yeah so in the paper we we do we
do presented that way
you have to be because we need you need
to have a setting where you can operate
arbitrary computation or some public
part and then the private part you only
do it in a product in the oblivious way
and both security and yes so so I wanted
to I'm not going to have time for the
proof but let me just quickly say that
the proof essentially is the fact that
in like look I pointed out in existing
ABC schemes they basically have this
property that the ciphertext looks like
an encryption of of the attribute and it
essentially allows you to hide the
attribute so we essentially little only
hide the efficacy when you guys that if
security that people so the proof is not
too hot you can do the whole thing
alright so going back to the question
that everyone has said you know so what
does this tell us about function
encryption for all circuits all right so
a sharpie state so what we present
essentially or a Spanish it also and why
she actually show is sort of a sort of a
bootstrapping type theorem that you know
it's efficient sort of to do partial
encryption for for for officially
decryption in some sense which
corresponds to just do it interpreter
grounding so essentially if you men
should built a partial encryption scheme
for this simple functionality of
interpreting so all you know how to do
without rounding you can do it for
interpretive routing then you get
function notation for circuits Rover the
construction has a property that your
cipher text is very short so it satisfy
this compactness requirement and this
very similar inter also give you a
prescription for circuits so really what
we show is in some sense that really is
this sufficient to just built function
encryption for very very simple function
this is a metatheorem not as a precise
statement because we need special
properties from we do is plug sort of a
so that algebra properties of the entire
scheme so to conclude let me conclude
certainly personal note I'm so I started
working on function encryption like
around 2010 when function encryption was
trending so this is a time when you know
I had no grants I had no tenure nothing
you know and then I decided to start
working on function encryption stuff for
the wrong reason because they appeared
to me that function encryption was
crypto complete maybe I'll be able to
get more papers I can get grants I can
get tenure five years later it's not
quite trending anymore instead of going
down and yeah I'm still working on
function encryption and and my
motivation has changed now I will
function the encryption because function
encryption script the complete in
particular it implies that this profile
reduction obfuscation we all think that
obfuscation script a complete function
encryption ratification selfish
encryption scriptor completes in fact
you know the some sense in which the
techniques developed in the content of
function encryption has already had a
huge impact on cryptography all cell
function encryption itself so today we
have some connections to fully
homomorphic encryption puli homomorphic
signatures one thing we none of us
talked about today sort of using
techniques from function encryption will
give you delegation signature CCA and so
forth so right so I hope somehow our
talks have sort of motivated some of you
to start thinking and working on partial
encryption and I look forward to the
next five years of functioning
this body signatures can you take a
signature and you can suck on something
else
think about this question of people are
crazy discussed a little bit on that you
could say and attack on an encryption on
top of it just the way you would take a
signature attack on the encryption
together nicely
what would you can exactly an
interruption the way to encrypt
the signatures buy you the normal
ability property so he helps you protect
against collisions but the dicks hard
part is to protect attribute and there's
something that doesn't seem to come from
and it comes thought of signature
guarantee signatures what is B and C one
of them is heavy with wasting paper so
it's very statement no no I'm not
leaving a gator oxygen excited over to
say go here but but there is a it is a
clear picture in the whole market
signature solution
but noting that the signatures in the
fully homomorphic signature scheme not
the secret key ABC scheme they are the
simulated secret keys and a B scheme
using a proof of security so the scheme
corresponds to proof of security which
is different from money transformation
for signatures where the the signing
algorithm is the key generation
algorithm in the fully commence its
nature the signing algorithm is the
simulator key generation algorithm used
in the proof of security it's not the
owners key generation so suddenly a lot
more delicate